after months of teases over watches new
hero sombra has finally been revealed
I'm Tony and this is your hacked
GameSpot news update as expected sombra
is an offensive character with some
tricky moves up her sleeve her primary
weapon is a machine pistol but she also
carries a translocator she can teleport
to wherever this is placed or even throw
it and warp while the device is still in
midair as a hacker she can also
temporarily stop opponents from using
their abilities or even render health
packs unusable sombra can also use her
thermoptic camouflage to go invisible
this boosts her speed but attacking
taking damage or using any abilities
shuts the camo off finally her ultimate
is an EMP blast that destroys enemy
barriers and shields and hacks all
enemies caught in its radius sabra was
announced alongside two new maps and in
arcade mode the first map is oasis and
the second is echo point Antarctica
which is actually where I spaced
character may was previously frozen
arcade mode will add exclusive maps and
alternate rule sets like 1v1 in 3v three
matches sombra arcade mode and the
arcade exclusive antarctica map will be
available on the public test realm next
week with Oasis coming in December to
keep up with all the latest on overwatch
you're already in the right place